clowns are the creepiest children's
entertainers on earth so naturally
they've been used a terrifying to like
grown-up film fans for decades from
homicidal aliens to gigolo Cowboys here
are our picks for the four best and four
worst clown movies of all time if you
haven't seen Terra fire congratulations
on your ability to sleep a full eight
hours without waking up in a cold sweat
an indie film that sat on the Shelf for
a few years before being released
Terra Fire is one of those rare horror
movies that doesn't seem to feel the
need to over explain this villain the
audience knows he's a clown and he's
probably demonic but that's about it
he's silence grinning and more than
delighted to go on a trip to slaughter
town anytime he can terrify err is a
low-budget horror movie spinning off an
even lower budget short film and it's
got love letter to the good old days of
horror dripping off of it like viscera
of a clown monsters chainsaw
it has gory practical effects it has
party girls getting mutilated and if
you're down with slash a throwback
sickness it's 100 percent worth looking
up
yes nineteen nineties TV version of it
is charming in a same way it's a slice
of horror film making from a simpler
time but it's just a bit organizing to
watch without the rose-colored glasses
of nostalgia don't get us wrong
Tim Curry's performance as penny wise as
fantastic it's a movie around him
hampered by a made-for-tv budget and
content restrictions that hasn't aged
well there's the barely animated giant
spider at the conclusion there's a rough
acting and a dramatic screaming about
penny wise being too mean there's the
filmmakers steadfast faith and they
usually outstanding Harry Anderson's
comedic stylings be able to carry the
day only to watch him
uncharacteristically drop the ball just
shy of three decades later it holds a
place in pop culture history as quite
possibly being the reason that every
other millennial seems to be afraid of
clowns watched with fresh eyes though
not very scary at all the words so bad
is good have been thrown around so much
so they've pretty much lost all meaning
at this point cultural interpretations
of what scam perm was just vanilla
flavored lameness evident flow over time
somewhere floating atop the tides of our
willingness to accept silliness there is
the unsinkable ship that is killer
clowns from outer space killer clowns
with a tough movie to sell on paper no
two ways about it it's a story of a
species of alien invaders who look act
and accessorized like clowns there
chips are like a circus tent and they
kill with an array of weapons including
pies if that sounds like a good time to
you
you're in luck there are rumblings of an
upcoming sequel from the original
creators John Wayne Gacy slist of
real-life atrocities is so long that
we'll likely never know the exact number
of deaths for which he was responsible
when the details of Casey's crimes are
laid out most people are inclined to
incentive lyric oil in horror and
disgust but a small sliver of the
world's population fears left and says
now that's a picture and a very
important man released in 2003 under the
names Gacy in the crawlspace this true
crime depiction of the life of John
Wayne Gacy juxtaposes has sadism against
his gigs working as a clown for local
events exploitative sensationalist and
featuring Adam Baldwin from Firefly it
also stars a guy who played Pee Wee's
bully and pee-wee's big adventure in the
title role so it might just ruin your
childhood when it was first announced a
Stephen King's it was being we adapted
for the big screen
fans of the 1990 TV movie might have
been skeptical but that lasted exactly
as long as it took for them to see Bill
skarsgård in character
yikes look the new hit movies aren't
perfect the CGI can be less than
impressive and the roar in satisfying
moments but as adaptations of million
page books about transdimensional
HS Horrors go there are hoots they
managed to pull believable performances
out of the child stars which is sort of
the filmmaking equivalent of landing on
Mars and Bill Hader is a revelation
which came as no surprise to fans of his
masterful work on HBO's Barry it is
hunger 1989's clown house is a slasher
in the same vein as every other
low-budget entry and the genre from that
era it follows a story of three brothers
being stalked by a trio of escaped
mental patients just as clowns and the
lusting for blood there are
misunderstandings and mix ups as tends
to happen in these situations at one
point a young Sam Rockwell in his film
debut gets stabbed into unconsciousness
the movie ends at the title card reading
quote no man can hide from as fears as
they are a part of him
they will always know where he is hiding
[Music]
and you know what that would have been
an okay ending to an unremarkable and
largely dull movie if it wasn't for the
real-world horror happening behind the
scenes on the set of the film director
victor salva abused one of clown house's
child stars and was convicted and
sentenced to three years in prison
ultimately serving less than half of his
sentence before popping back onto the
scene to direct powder in 1995 his
career has continued with movies like
the Jeepers Creepers franchise and the
constant low-grade public curiosity as
to how disguiser has a career cold
filmmaker Bobcat Goldthwait as a
national treasure once a comedian named
for is aggressively annoying persona
he's become a director whose movies tend
to be tragic complicated peculiar
excessive and agonizing before world's
greatest dad and god bless america
he wrote and directed a movie called
shakes the clown and it's been dividing
critics and audiences ever since the
elevator pitch version is that it's a
story of an alcoholic birthday clown
who's framed for murder and herself Fox
a borderline mad max level gangs of
performers who've all the entertainment
circuits the more complicated version is
that ass Goldthwait's representation of
the comedy cliques that exists at every
open mic community in America some
critics called it amazing some call it
terrible perhaps the highest praise came
Believe It or Not from Martin Scorsese
who called it the Citizen Kane of
alcoholic clown movies okay salute over
the years it has become almost a rites
of passage for a successful band to dip
their toes into the world of Hollywood
The Beatles had classics like help and
Yellow Submarine the Spice Girls
irrevocably changed the geography and
political structure of the earth when
they terraformed the planet into a newer
better spice world and in 2010 a posse
of chemically imbalanced clowns proved
once and for all that just because you
can't figure out magnets doesn't mean
you can't run a camera big money
rustlers has a longer way to follow up
to 2000 ones big money Hustlas the first
insane clown posse movie it's set in the
wild American West of 1837 for some
reason visually it appears to being shot
on a budget of whatever loose change has
wedged into the cushions of their insane
clown couches the script seemed to have
been less written and more found
somewhere bigger money rustlers was
pretty obviously a movie made for the
fans
it's goofy and weird but if you don't
care at all about ICP
whole thing is just borderline
unwatchable
[Applause]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite cinematic clowns are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and at the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]